-Hey, you guys, be sure
to tune in Wednesday night.
-Why's that?
-Something very exciting
is going down --
we're taking "The Tonight Show"
into "Fortnite."
-Ooh.
-That's right. We've teamed up
with Samsung to do this.
It's called
"Tonight at the Rock,
Powered by Samsung Galaxy."
It's a gaming experience
you can play in "Fortnite."
We recreated everything --
Rockefeller Center,
the "30 Rock" building,
our offices --
every little detail
of the studio,
it's like you're right here,
and the attention to detail
is pretty mind-blowing.
You can explore around.
There's all these mini games
you can play, games we play
on "The Tonight Show"
and games that we made
just for "Fortnite"
with Samsung Galaxy Power Boost.
It's really cool.
We're very excited.
So call all your friends
around the world
and start playing.
Tune into the show
Wednesday night,
and thank you to "Fortnite"
and thank you
to everyone at Samsung.
It's good. It's cool.
-I got to see it.